-Guys, we have exactly
eight shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time
for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for
"12 Days of Christmas Sweaters."
♪♪
-♪ 12 days
of Christmas sweaters ♪
♪ 8 days left ♪
-That is right!
Every show between now
and Christmas,
we'll be giving one lucky
audience member
a jaw-dropping Christmas sweater
from the Countdown to Christmas
Cabinet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, since -- Oh, yeah.
We don't mess around.
Since there are
eight shows left,
let's open door number eight.
Where is it?
Oh, even just the door --
even the door looks exciting.
Alright. Let's see it.
Wow. I need more.
I need more. Let's see.
Let's take it out.
Let's see what it is.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ohh.
Oh.
-Ooh!
-Wow.
That's interesting.
It's like a bonus.
There's, like,
a floating collar.
a bonus collar there.
that's like a floating collar.
Let's see the back.
Let's see.
Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
From "The Tonight Show."
A holiday fruit cake.
Alright, let's see who's gonna
go home with tonight's sweater.
Everyone look at your
seat number, okay?
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get
a drum roll, please?
[ Drum roll ]
Who wants this one?
It's a good one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
419!
Can we unzip it?
Unzip it, unzip it.
♪♪
Hi, bud! Hi!
[ Laughs ]
Come on!
We have the best audience
in the world.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Can I put it on?
-What is your name?
-I'm Paige.
It's so nice to meet you.
-Hey, where you from?
-I'm from Chicago.
-Hey, welcome.
I'm so happy that you're here.
-Thank you so much!
-Thank you for being here.
Now, it's very cold in Chicago.
Even when it's warm,
it's cold in Chicago.
Do you have anything like this?
-I have nothing like this.
The lapels are gorgeous.
-Thank you so much.
I stitched it myself.
Would you like to try it on?
-I would love to try it on.
-Okay, here we go.
[ Audience cheering ]
Oh, this is good.
You can tell already.
Gorgeous.
Do you want to zip it?
Try zipping it.
Yeah, you got to zip it.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yes!
Look at this.
Look at that.
Are you kidding me?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Supermodel!
Thank you so much.
Congratulations again.
Guys, stick around.
We're playing "Can You Feel It"
with Nicole Kidman
after the break.
Come on back.
♪♪